da darf sie alle recht herzlich
willkommen heißen hier im willy brandt
haus sie bekommen das mit wir sind jetzt
dabei nach der wahl und zu sortieren
heute haben wir rolf mützenich mit einem
überragenden ergebnis zum
fraktionsvorsitzenden gewählt hat das
große vertrauen bekommen gestern eine
wirklich tolle auch emotionale
fraktionssitzungen der 104 neue
kolleginnen und kollegen mit sehr
bewegenden geschichten sich vorgestellt
haben also alle waren glaube ich sehr
stolz auf das was wir in den letzten
wochen auch durch diesen fulminanten
sieg bei der wahl dann erreicht haben
diese aufholjagd die da war die alle
auch noch einmal bestärkt hat und das
merkt man in der spd fraktion wir haben
am montag im präsidium im parteivorstand
einstimmig jeweils gesagt wir wollen
jetzt gespräche führen mit den grünen
mit der fdp und wollen jetzt sehr zügig
zu einer stabilen regierung kommen haben
wir haben in den letzten tagen mit den
generalsekretären vertrauensvoll über
diese frage auch geredet sie haben alle
mitbekommen dass der zeitplan jetzt
steht wir werden uns am
sonntagnachmittag mit der fdp treffen am
sonntagabend dann mit den grünen und
werden den gesprächen für einsteigen mit
dem festen willen von unserer seite dann
eine regierung zu bilden die künftige
regierung das will ich ja auch sagen hat
drei große aufgaben die erledigt werden
müssen das eine ist wir müssen so
aufgestellt sein dass wir die großen
zukunftsaufgaben dieses landes anpacken
können geht um klimaschutz es geht um
digitalisierung staatsmodernisierung es
muss eine regierung sein die europa
wieder stärker in den mittelpunkt rückt
es muss eine regierung sein die zweitens
eine andere art des politikmachens auch
definiert also eine regierung in der es
nicht um gewinner und verlierer geht
sondern wo stabil unter
koalitionspartnern zusammengearbeitet
wird die schwarz gelbe regierung 2009
bis 2013 ist das abschreckende beispiel
genauso was wollen wir nicht sondern ein
vertrauensvolles verhältnis zwischen den
akteuren dieser regierung und die dritte
aufgabe die eine künftige regierung zu
leisten hat ist eine junge generation
wirklich auch für politik zu gewinnen
haben die themen anzupacken die für eine
junge generation wichtig sind haben und
anzugehen dass das vertrauen einer
jungen generation im politik wächst
vielen dank
wir haben unsere verhandlungsgruppe ja
genannt das ist der kanzlerkandidat olaf
scholz die beiden parteivorsitzenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden malu dreyer für
die länder und dass wir nicht als
generalsekretär und von den anderen
parteien werden dann jeweils auch
delegationen da sind
werden auch delegationen dasein das
legen die fest aber für uns kann ich nur
sagen werden ist die 6
das ziel ist jetzt am sonntag in
gespräche einzusteigen ich habe gerade
benannt was für uns wichtig ist die
frage der großen herausforderungen gibt
es dafür ein gemeinsames verständnis
natürlich wird man auch darüber reden wo
sind knackpunkte das ist ja
offensichtlich dass wir nicht alle mit
den gleichen inhalten auch in den
wahlkampf gegangen sind und dann wird
man danach auswerten wie dieses gespräch
gelaufen ist
[Musik]
frage die aktiv leben wir ja am samstag
mit der union reden und kommt das
dementierte dass ich ein bisschen dafür
zu achten nein ich bin ich irritiert
sagt ihr noch entscheidend ist wer am
ende den koalitionsvertrag unterschreibt
nicht wir am anfang die ersten gespräche
führt und da bin ich sehr guter dinge es
gibt drei parteien die die wahl gewonnen
haben drei parteien wo der balken nach
oben geht unser festes ziel ist eine
koalition der gewinner zu schmieden und
dafür zu sorgen dass diese koalition der
gewinner auch die großen
herausforderungen des landes anpacken
kann und was die konkreten gespräche am
sonntag angeht bitte ich um verständnis
dass wir unter den generalsekretären
gesagt haben wir machen jetzt den
zeitplan öffentlich wir kommen denn am
sonntag zusammen aber genaue uhrzeiten
länge des gespräches das wird sich jetzt
auf der strecke
wir haben die einladung montag
ausgesprochen aber das waren jetzt
einfach gespräche unter den
generalsekretären die er seit wochen
schon vertrauensvoll sind sie wissen
dass wir ihnen vernünftigen draht haben
also das ist jetzt nicht so dass sie
einen gesagt haben wir laden euch ein
und die anderen danach denken mussten
ist es so dass wir einfach jetzt auf der
strecke entschieden haben wir treffen
uns dann sonntag
wir haben am montag klar gemacht
einstimmig in beiden gremien wir wollen
mit grünen und der fdp reden das ist
jetzt der wille den wir als spd haben
und da gibt es gerade keinen plan b
ganz r gestern schon mal da war ich
gestern schon genannten bewältigt und
grünen und fdp machten sie schon auf
leitlinien geeinigt die ärgerlich ist es
für die spd dass wieder 100 wahlsieger
als letzte gefragt werden meint dass es
ist doch wichtig bei den aufgaben die
ich gerade beschrieben habe dass es ein
vertrauensvolles miteinander gibt und da
ist doch gut wenn jetzt gerade gespräche
stattfinden wenn dinge geklärt werden
wenn dinge auf den weg gebracht werden
und das wird jetzt eine ganze
reihenfolge von gesprächen geben noch
mal wichtig ist wir haben ende den
koalitionsvertrag unterschreibt und da
bin ich sehr optimistisch dass das am
ende die parteien sein werden die auch
den auftrag der wählerinnen und wähler
bekommen haben also die 34 der balken am
sonntag nach oben gegangen ist
wir werden dann auch darüber reden wie
man kommuniziert an welchen stellen man
kommuniziert ich glaube es gibt
beispiele aus der vergangenheit wo man
sagen kann da war kommunikation in
verhandlungen gelungen und es gibt
welche wo das nicht so gelungen war und
da werden wir eine gemeinsame linie
finden aber erstmal sehr schön wenn alle
gestern da auch im guten abend hatten
das ist sehr wichtig um künftig zusammen
zu regieren